momento de hablar de economía france24 y
por eso os saludo a mi compañero jorge
hurtado jorge iniciamos economía
hablando de la intervención de alemania
en la filial alemana del gigante ruso
gazprom robe árabe quien es el ministro
de economía y de energía de alemania
confirmó la noticia de que su país había
tomado control de la filial de gazprom
según él la medida es para asegurar el
suministro de energía y las
infraestructuras críticas desde ahora el
regulador energético alemán se
convertirá en el administrador de gas
pero en alemania hasta el 30 de
septiembre el viernes gazprom anunció
que se retiraba de sufrir a la alemana
sin revelar una nueva estructura de
propiedad la filial alemana posee varios
activos energéticos claves como el
proveedor de gas natural wind gas que
tiene una cuota de mercado del 20 por
ciento en alemania también posee la
empresa de almacenamiento de gas hasta
ahora una rama comercial con sede en
londres y otras filiales extranjeras
pese a que alemania podía las sanciones
occidentales contra moscú por la
invasión en ucrania su gran dependencia
de las importaciones de energía rusa ha
hecho que berlín
se ha quitado de los llamados a
boicotear el petróleo y el gas ruso
escuchemos un poco lo que dijo el
ministro
el paso es imperativo la seguridad del
suministro está actualmente garantizada
el trasfondo de la decisión es entre
otras cosas la falta de claridad en las
relaciones jurídicas así como el
incumplimiento de las obligaciones de
información en virtud de la ordenanza de
comercio exterior y pagos
sin red software no jorge algunos
gobiernos de américa latina comienzan a
aplicar medidas para amortiguar el golpe
que supone la guerra en ucrania por
ejemplo el ejecutivo de uruguay envió
hoy a la asamblea de ese país una
propuesta para eliminar por un mes
completo el iva del pan blanco y la
pasta en un texto oficial el ejecutivo
argumenta que la guerra en ucrania ha
provocado una subida significativa de
los precios de combustibles y algunos
granos generando mayor presión
inflacionaria este texto también propone
exonerar de oliva por 30 días a las
enajenaciones correspondientes a la
etapa minorista del pan blanco común a
un tipo de pan casero a las pastas y a
los fideos días antes el gobierno
propuso exonerar del iva
al asado de tira con hueso este es uno
de los cortes de carne más tradicionales
que existen en ese país jorge y reino
unido- se abre a la posibilidad de usar
cripto monedas cuéntenos así lo dijo
john glenn quien es el secretario de
economía el secretario estado de
economía aspira que el reino unido se
convierte en un lugar hospitalario para
las kryptos monedas el ministerio de
economía y dijo que prevé formalizar
algunas cripto monedas estables como
forma válida de pago reino unido
considera que las cripto monedas
estables que son aquellas cuyo valor
está ligado al de las divisas
tradicionales como el dólar
estadounidense pueden ofrecer métodos
eficientes de pago ese país revisará a
la fiscalidad asociada a los préstamos y
otros servicios financieros con cripto
monedas entre particulares conocidos
como finanzas descentralizadas o de fin
el ministro dijo que existe preocupación
por la cantidad de energía que consume
la minería de cripto monedas pero que
buscan impulsar al reino unido como un
centro líder mundial en finanzas verdes
porque ahora vamos a áfrica
particularmente a kenia porque se vive
otro día de escasez por culpa de las
compras de pánico como ahí hay un
estricto racionamiento de las
gasolineras que generó enormes filas
durante el fin de semana el gobierno
culpó al acaparamiento y a las compras
de pánico de la situación pero los
distribuidores de petróleo dijeron que
se le debían pagos de subsidios
pendientes por parte del estado en
muchos lugares de nairobi los
automovilistas que pudieron encontrar
gasolina después de muchas horas de cola
recibieron una cantidad relacionada la
crisis empezó tras una disputa entre las
empresas de comercialización de petróleo
y el gobierno sobre el pago de estos
subsidios según datos oficiales kenia
consume casi 400 millones de litros de
gasolina y diésel al mes momento de
conocer los indicadores
empezamos en eeuu precisamente en los
principales índices de wall street- que
subieron este lunes impulsados por los
valores tecnológicos y la subida de
twitter después de que el amor se
revelara su participación en esta
empresa en europa la bolsa de londres
subió este lunes pese a las caídas en el
sector bancario mientras los inversores
siguen pendientes de la evolución de la
guerra en ucrania y en américa latina la
bolsa mexicana de valores registró un
retroceso del 0 y 2 % en su principal
indicador por las ganancias
empresariales por ejecutado con la
información económica muchas gracias y
ustedes televidentes también muchas
gracias por sintonizarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]